Hey, YouTube, it's BTS Week
at "The Tonight Show,"
and every day,
we're bringing you
incredible new performances
from the group.
Here now
to perform the song "Home"
from their 2019 EP
"Map of the Soul: Persona,"
BTS.
I was too nervous
So I couldn't say hi
Yeah, I'm going out, baby
The whole world is my home
Oh!
Crazy for myself
When I open that door,
I feel like I could do anything
Like I can show all I got
I left home
I hope all this imagination
isn't gonna vanish like a mirage
Oh, yeah, I did it
Me shine with flashin' lights
Got a lotta friends
My quiet and cozy place
Yes, I remember the moment
when I thought I could do
anything
I saw the ocean, yeah
Before even opening this door
Oh, yeah
I'm trying to fill it up
but feeling emptier
We're together,
but I'm feeling lonelier
Half-closed eyes
Sleepless nights
The place where you are
Maybe that is Mi casa
With you, I'mma feel rich (rich)
Hey
Yes, it's Mi Casa (Mi Casa)
In advance,
turn on your Switch (Switch)
Yeah
Even if there's no words,
it would be comfy
If you are there,
it's gonna be my home
You know I want that
Home
You know you got that
Your love, your love, your love
I miss that
I want that
Your touch, your touch,
your touch
I need that
La-la-la-la-la la-la-la-la-la
I love it
At the porch with no lights,
my feet feel weird
With my eyes closed,
I still feel weird
Dong, feeling hype
Bing, dizzy eyes
At this awesome place
What? (I feel so humble)
So humble
The world knows we got
all the world
I got things I dreamed of
Big house, big cars, big rings
Even though I got everything
I wanted, I feel empty
Feels strange to have it all
But since I got a place
to come back, I left home
At a crossroads
I can't forget (can't forget)
The one who saw small me
You (You)
I can smile thinking about you
The place where you are
Maybe that is Mi casa
With you, I'mma feel rich
Yes, it's Mi Casa (Mi Casa)
In advance,
turn on your Switch (Switch)
Yeah
Even if there's no words,
it would be comfy
If you are there,
it's gonna be my home
You know I want that
Home
You know you got that
One day
If the doorbell rings 3 times
Would you open the door?
I want to say hi, I missed it
I'll tell you then
Long time no see
Mi Casa
With you, I just feel rich
Hey
I'm home. Hi, Mi Casa
(Mi Casa)
Turned on your Switch
(Switch) Yeah
It's comfy, no words needed
Since you're here,
it's now my home
You know I want that
Home
You know you got that
Your love, your love, your love
I miss that
I want that
Your touch, your touch,
your touch
I need that
La-la-la-la-la la-la-la-la-la
I love it